every time you do it they have to start
with somebody
what'd she do but turn it on rihanna is
the tech genius behind a plot to steal a
diamond necklace from the Met Gala in
oceans eight but in reality she's used
to stealing the red carpet at the ultra
glitzy event it is happening Monday with
a singer co-hosting and since this is
flashback Friday here our RiRi is most
remarkable Met Gala looks I'm going Tom
Ford and reports of jewelry it looks
cream thank you
yes of course I know it looks really
difficult to wear but it's it's really
stretchy very cleverly made they take
you long to get dressed tonight no the
dress in part was easy when nails took
forever
[Music]
why'd you pick this lunch I just wanted
to wear something
elegant fulfillment
where exactly a gown but I wanted
she knows the fabric and we collaborated
on this bank so it was fun 3 Ruiz
Michaelis style transformation has gone
from simple wearing this white halter
with black mesh gloves to edgy this
black pantsuit and those shoulders
though black lace and a long red braid
sleek and a black croc and boss dress
then white and showing skin but in 2015
RiRi dropped the mic when she showed up
in this the gown weighed 55 pounds and
she needed 3 people to help her up the
famous met steps the dress sparked a ton
of memes so I'm comparing it to
scrambled eggs pizza and Big Bird is
handmade by one drink use one woman it's
2 years to me so just how does RiRi
pecker look well she definitely does her
research and sticks with the theme
[Music]